hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week besides sweating
we're talking about cmmccontrol au.l
2-3.3.4 Alert in the event of an audit
logging process failure and speaking of
a failure I have a failure to put on
deodorant before I came and started
shooting videos under incredibly warm
spotlights and I'm about to gas my
camera guy out but you guys get to watch
this video without smell-o-vision
[Music]
thank you
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of this
cmmc dfars and nist sp-80171 compliant
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you I actually did not forget to put on
deodorant today but it does still stink
in here and we just need to open a door
just kidding you found your home here at
on-call compliance Solutions we can help
you transform into your on your
company's on-call compliance hero and
not stink so bad let's jump into it so
in cmmc control
au.l1-3.3.4 Alert in the event of an
audit logging process failure so this
control Dives even deeper into the
required functionality of the seam
system
okay seam systems need to be able to
alert you to when there is an issue
causing the system to not work correctly
otherwise how would you know when there
has been tampering with or a malfunction
in your security system right so again
we have to have a tamper-proof system so
how do we do that well let's check out
what the assessors are really looking
for here and how to make them happy
all right three assessment points number
one determinive Personnel or roles to be
alerted in the event of an audit logging
process failure are identified now this
one's actually pretty easy it sounds a
little intimidating when you first read
it but as it turns out hey look you've
probably got a seam system right right
if not call us we can help all right
Implement BSC solution only authorize
team administrators receive these alerts
so again we are defining who's getting
those alerts and all we have to do
really is just sort of give a
demonstration show them what the role is
of the administrator standard user in
our seam system you know whatever it may
be now number two determine if types of
audit logging process failures for which
alert will be generated are defined
again implemented via seam solution the
seam solution alert alerts seam admins
to audit logging process failures so
again we can clearly demonstrate this by
allowing in the same system showing them
these are admin users that have access
to it and that they are getting the
alerts uh Point number three determine
if identified Personnel or roles are
alerted in the event of an audit logging
process failure
now this is an interesting one right a
little bit different uh now it is hey
does your seam system alert you if
there's an actual failure to get the
logs from the endpoints or if there's a
failure in its own system right that is
a necessary part of a seam system when
complying with nist SP 800171 and of
course cmmc so again we'll say hey
Implement via the same solution the same
solution alerts seem admins to audio
logging process failures I'm gonna be
honest this is a very interesting one to
prove uh you know normally these things
are pretty straightforward kind of
self-service if you will I have found
that with a lot of seam systems the only
way to really prove this is honestly
with a support ticket into the vendor to
ask what their policies are so it is a
little bit challenging uh and it's not
always something that's really super uh
sort of at your hands but again we found
that again a simple support ticket may
be your answer there now here's the good
news uh if you're a defense contractor
we can help out with all of this
compliance stuff okay because we work
with defense contractors just like you
who've had this dfars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day we teach
you how to level up and be a proper
on-call compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps great areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance as your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you visit
cmmc compliance secrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better Hulk smash that subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliances roll
it out until next compliance tip my
friends stay safe and secure out there
hit us in the comments below to let us
know what you'd like to know more about
when it comes to information security
and compliance I'll see you on the next
one
[Music]